Neko is about to do something crazy just
drop the tape and dirt he's about to
drop a tape in dirt one tape please one
tape I've heard that lipo batteries are
really dangerous so this really puffed
up lipo battery it's really old battery
it's been used a million times a million
times
slight exaggeration anyways you're not
supposed to use when they get puffy I
figured let's see what happens if i
pierce it through the heart with an
arrow where is the heart of the battery
located
all right smack dab Center batteries
like the heart of your electronics thank
you and I don't know what it actually is
come on what you think's gonna happen I
have no basis up what's going to happen
Nick what he thinks it happen I think
it's going to plug in this brand-new an
engineer will explode
no comments about the tape you watered
the bores oh one my own fire it's not
falling down this time hoping this is a
little bit of a show I'm hoping that we
have enticed you with an exploding
battery just have it sit there do I
people are you
[Applause]
[Music]
was great that totally makes sense
because it is not a 3-cell battery yeah
three three burnings that far surpassed
my expectations only crap that was
amazing yeah we didn't want to render
like we wanted Ren to hype it up the
beginning to make it like the video
seemed all exciting but he wouldn't do
it cuz he's like I'm an engineering
student and batteries don't explode
no I turns out Ren's expectations were
surpassed dude look at the era
dude the thing is when you charge it all
that electricity releases all at once
what oh oh there's still an arrow in
there I don't wear this hat people will
know what channel I'm with until they
weren't lying about lipo batteries look
at that dude straight-up explode yeah
close it I just shot out a jet of flame
like this moment oh that's cool I wish I
could knew your guys doing
from watch I guess you can watch the
replay one take first strike I can do
this yeah okay one take first struck
first right first right first right
Allen take a scratch and believe me hit
it like cable you data perfectly on the
first take per stretch one take for a
strike leg back here yep there we go
ladies and gentlemen this is the last
day to get your very own corridor
digital hat the reason we do them
limited edition is because we actually
have to make them to order so we take
the number of people that ordered them
we make that many hats so if you want
one today is the day I'm personally a
big fan of the new yellow and black
colors there's on average about 4 to 5
people working in this studio Nick and I
can't always be there to film them we
have a great workshop designed for the
builders not the cameramen simply put we
need a top-down rig I'm going to build
the best moving top-down rig for this
workshop top-down rigs only 224 dollars
- to the camera - the camera the light
here's the plan for the top-down rig
that Spencer 9 designed first we're
going to mount brackets onto the walls
then we string up two sets of wires
across the room horizontally on both
sides that provides us lateral movement
from left to right the next step is to
cut two boards that go on those cables
with one board on each side of the room
we attach them with four cables and four
tensioners these boards have four pulley
wheels on the back of them so they can
slide left to right on the cables next
step is to cut and build a camera dolly
that goes in the center of these four
cables which allow us to go bilaterally
across the room in the way that we
couldn't before
Spencer has built the entire top-down
rig as a 3d model in 3ds max functional
we can have a better idea physically
what it's going to be
[Music]
is the very unfunny part be curious they
probably has a tool to do this but I
don't own it so you just can't screwing
it for now I have to stick thing in and
rotate thing
[Music]
one take first try one take first try
first try one try not take it
are you illegal that which is fixed
reality video for no they've been doing
it for a couple weeks now
Lily Moni you okay yeah the video that
just came out today looks crazy yeah
yeah like as a visual effects guy I
think you really appreciate it we
figured out a way we take 1/3 controller
that's tracked in 3d space and you put
it on the camera and that gives you a
virtual camera that's doing the same
thing your real-life camera is doing so
you take the footage from the virtual
camera you combine with the footage from
the real camera it looks like the stuff
you're killing in real life as long as
it's on a green screen it looks like
it's in that virtual space so there's
this game called Gorn which is a
fighting game it works flawlessly with
mixed reality like it's more ground
layers the key to this is having those
foreground layer yeah it keeps tracking
where the headset is in space and any
models between the headset in the camera
it renders out as a separate layer the
part where Sam grabs two arms and just
arts like pounding the ground with them
oh look at this
we were grazie that looks the tracking
like the foreground layers the
compositing like it all works out so
well like I'm in that space just making
blood triangles fly everywhere we should
do like an entire short film based yeah
okay I think we should do the visual
effects side me is like really excited
about this I really want to make a gif
of this like dig this to fit the front
page read it I'll do it
all right when this vlog is posted and
I'll put a link in the comments so you
guys can go up with it we gave the front
page reddit which you guys I could get
making tutorial you would let us on the
comments below and we will put one in
one of our upcoming vlogs and maybe we
can actually do like a little gift Film
Festival it really makes give some I
know their favorite parts from Sam and
Eko video or something like that already
like a billion corridor digital gifts
out there but 70 go channel needs a
little bit of love you guys wanna check
out the full video it's on note so head
on over there to watch us live in the
virtual realm isn't all the the big
their weekend stuff going up soon yeah
like all the nerf game yeah every
everyone's day now going towards a real
everyone
the next two months yeah moly as big a
small said if you don't know no ha how's
it fit fits in good good we're ready to
string our first layer and then we need
to cut some wood the first set of wheels
on tension some more and we'll be would
be golden time to swedge what does is
that we have this little piece of
aluminum here and a sweater closes that
loom them down on it so it doesn't move
without really actually tightening the
middle increase the tension of the walls
you're the ex engineer is that more of
an exponential pull or is it more of a
linear Pole yeah Lenny linear increase
yeah the crux of the issue is that you
need to be able to make this really
really tight so that this doesn't sag
the issue is that when you do that now
you're pulling this away putting a lot
of extra tension on these wires which
are attached to the walls I really want
to know how many pounds were pulling on
the wall there there's only so much a
2x4 can hold here it's a matter of how
strong is a connection of the 2x4 to the
roof for whatever studs that the 2x4
studs are connected to
I'm won't worry about like here because
this is a pressure point where the
threads are digging into the wood so
you're saying you think that this your
point itself might fail
I think I think I think that's your
point will fail before anything else for
sure
our plan of attack as I said is we leave
the top ones on we place one wire at a
time making it as tight as we can with
like unscrewing these I'd say yeah just
one at a time pull these cables until
the whole system's tight from a
technical standpoint this should be
easier than dealing with poles and
finding the hardware and cheaper
I feel like filling the pole wrap would
have been easier be honest
just want to go home seal down my face